nos piden encontrar estos tres límites y
como siempre los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver esto por
su cuenta para resolver el primer límite
quizá pensemos calcular primero el
límite de fx cuando x tiende a menos 2
luego calcular el límite de gx cuando x
tiende a menos 2 y al final sumar ambos
límites pero pronto vemos el problema
aquí si calculamos el límite de fx
cuando x tiende a menos 2 desde la
izquierda parece que se acerca a 1 pero
derecha parece que se acerca a 3 por lo
que no existe límite de fx cuando x
tiende a menos 2 lo mismo sucede con gdx
si tiende a menos 2 desde la izquierda
se acerca a 3 y si tiende a menos 2
desde la derecha se acerca a 1 pero
resulta que este límite puede que sí
exista siempre y cuando el límite cuando
x tiende a menos 2 desde la izquierda de
fx + gx sea igual al límite cuando x
tiende a menos 2 desde la derecha de fx
+ gx
el límite de fx cuando x tiende a menos
2 desde la izquierda es 1 y el límite de
gx cuando x tiende a menos 2 desde la
izquierda es 3 y parece que el límite de
la suma tiende a 4 si vemos el límite de
fx cuando x tiende a menos 2 desde la
derecha se acerca a 3 y el límite de gx
cuando x tiende a menos 2 desde la
derecha se acerca a 1 y la suma de estos
límites es igual a 4 y ya que los
límites desde la derecha y desde la
izquierda son iguales podemos decir que
este límite si existe y es igual a 4
analicemos el segundo ejemplo cuando x
tiende a 1 vamos a hacer lo mismo que en
el ejemplo anterior de nuevo podemos ver
que si analizamos los límites
individuales de fx cuando x tiende a 1
desde la izquierda y desde la derecha el
límite no existe pero el límite de la
suma así podría existir vamos a
resolverlo el límite cuando x tiende a 1
desde la izquierda de fx más g
a que es igual si x tiende a 1 desde la
izquierda de fx parece que se acerca 2 y
el límite cuando x tiende a 1 desde la
izquierda de gx parece que se acerca a 0
esta suma es 2 + 0 igualados y ahora
veamos el límite cuando x tiende a 1
desde la derecha de fx + gx el límite de
fx cuando x tiende a 1 desde la derecha
se acerca a menos 1 y en el caso de gm x
parece que el límite se acerca a 0
también esta suma se acerca a menos 1 en
este caso los límites desde la izquierda
y desde la derecha son diferentes por lo
que el límite de la suma no existe
finalmente veamos el límite cuando x
tiende a 1 de fx por gd x hacemos lo
mismo el límite cuando x tiende a 1
desde la izquierda de fx por gd x vemos
que para f x cuando x tiende a 1 desde
la izquierda es 2 y para ge x cuando x
tiende a 1 desde la
izquierda es 0 2 por 0 0 por lo que
parece que este límite desde la derecha
se acerca a 0 ahora analicemos el límite
cuando x tiende a 1 desde la derecha de
fx por gd x ya vimos que para f x cuando
x tiende a 1 desde la derecha el límite
se acerca a menos 1 y si vemos lo mismo
para ge x el límite se acerca a 0 menos
1 x 0 es igual a 0 por lo que este
límite si existe es el mismo valor
cuando se acerca desde la derecha y
cuando se acerca desde la izquierda y
este valor es igual a 0 todos estos
ejemplos son interesantes porque a veces
nos encontramos que los límites de los
componentes no existen para cierto valor
y pensamos que quizá el límite de la
suma o el producto de esos componentes
no existe pero aquí vimos dos ejemplos
en donde estos límites si existen con
eso terminamos y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo